just want to bring you a bit of breaking
news now and labor has reported Boris
Johnson to the Parliamentary
commissioner for standards over
allegations that the BBC chairman
Richard Sharp helped the former prime
minister to arrange a guarantee on a
loan of up to 800 000 pounds that was
just weeks before Boris Johnson selected
him for his current job now annalize
dogs labor party chair has written to
Daniel Greenberg raising concerns about
the arrangement which has not been
published in the register of members
Financial interests Mr suggests that the
arrangement could have constituted a
breach of the code of conduct for MPS by
raising the possibility of a conflict of
interest for the Prime Minister and
through failing to appropriately declare
the arrangement so just to reiterate on
that piece of breaking news coming into
US Labor has reported Boris Johnson to
the Parliamentary commissioner for
standards over allegations that the BBC
chairman chart helped the former prime
minister arranged a guarantee on a loan
of up to 800
000 pounds